sam heslop's friends describe her as a
free spirit
who loves to travel her latest adventure
was to the caribbean
to be with her boyfriend on his
catamaran but sam hasn't been seen
since the 7th of march at first i didn't
believe it i was like okay well she's
probably gone out
partying somewhere and we'll probably
hear from her in a couple of days
but uh yeah when she didn't turn up
on the monday or the tuesday or the
wednesday or today
reality is hitting and hitting hard
but it's not giving no one's giving up
sam from southampton
and her boyfriend ryan bain were working
on his catamaran in saint john in the
u.s virgin islands
the night she disappeared they'd been
out for dinner before returning to the
boat
anchored off frank bay bane woke in the
night to find her missing
her friends are extremely worried for
her safety she would not leave
possessions uh just sat on the boat and
i
truly believe knowing something as i do
that she would have
reached out to a friend locally she
there
she has friends locally in the in the
caribbean she has friends
in england she would have reached out
and asked for help if she needed it i
know that
police divers have been searching local
waters and ryan baine's lawyer
says they've searched his catamaran in a
statement to sky news he said
ryan bain contacted the virgin islands
police department at approximately 2 30
am
on march 8 right after he found psalm
missing
mr bane then immediately met members of
the police on shore in saint john
he is devastated that sam is missing and
is praying that she is found safe
sam had moved to the caribbean for love
and to follow her dream of becoming a
chef on board her boyfriend's boat
now her loved ones grow increasingly
desperate as they wonder
and fear what might have happened to
psalm becky cottrell
sky news